[Musique]
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités
merci de nous rejoindre donc en ce début
de semaine et nous parlerons notamment
de sport aujourd'hui d'ailleurs de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin
depuis 2003 max vignes et quitte la
présidence retour sur ces années et sur
les raisons de son départ également à
nous irons aussi à trappes sur le site
de météo france jean-françois doug et
prévisionnistes nous expliquera les
raisons du climat actuel et vous verrez
que cela n'a rien de si exceptionnel
mais pour le moment politique alors
qu'il vient de démissionner du
gouvernement emmanuel macron doit
maintenant récolter de l'argent pour
espérer lancer à sa campagne
présidentielle avec son mouvement
politique en marche en attendant ses
militants à s'activent sur le terrain
invité ce soir aziz françois n'diaye
c'est le référent yvelinois du mouvement
en marche nous allons voir avec lui
comment se passe cette mobilisation
bonsoir asie sponsoring choix remercie
d'être venu sur ce plateau aujourd'hui
est-ce que la mobilisation de vos
militants du mouvement en marche est
forte sur le terrain et plus
particulièrement dans les yvelines très
forte très forte d'une part parce que
beaucoup étaient en attente de la sortie
du gouvernement des modèles macro et je
peux vous dire que sur la seule journée
de sa sortie douze mille adhérents
supplémentaires c'est colossal plan
parle à l'échelle nationale comme à
l'échelle nationale son département sur
les départements particulièrement on n'a
pas encore les chiffres normalement ça
devrait sortir très peu de façon ciblée
mais
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 75000 un peu
plus d'adhérence sur l'ensemble du
territoire je peux vous dire que le
département des yvelines est très très
mobilisé et nous faisons je pense partie
des premiers départements en termes de
nombre et particulièrement ce qui me
frappe dans cette mobilisation c'est que
nous avons des gens qui viennent de
toutes catégories sociales ce que je
vais vous demander le profil un petit
peu des deux tout âge d'autres
catégories sociales de tout âge et
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup avec un fort
taux de premier engagement
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
frappant c'est qu'au moment où les
français se désengage de la chose
politique nous avons de plus en plus de
gens qui nous rejoignent et pour qui
c'est le premier engagement ce qui est
mon cas des risques est votre cas parce
que vous êtes un entrepreneur et vous
n'étiez auparavant n'étiez jamais
engagée dans aucun parti effective qu
est ce qui a fait la différence la
différence elle vient surtout du fait
qu' il y avait un fort désir
d'engagement comme chez beaucoup de
français qui sont très entreprenants
mais qui malheureusement n'ont pas
toujours trouvé la possibilité de
s'exprimer et emmanuel macron nous a
donné cette chance de pouvoir agir et
agir sur le terrain concrètement
j'allais dire avec bienveillance sans
sens sans esprit ni politicien ni ni ni
ni préjugés et chacun trouve sa place
pour peu qu'ils aient envie d'agir et ça
c'est quelque chose qui me parle moi je
je je n'ai jamais été je n'ai jamais
pensé pouvoir faire un jour ce type
d'engagement mais son discours la
sincérité avec laquelle il ressent
l'envié d'agir pour le pays moi m'a
touché et m'a dit écoutez si ceux ci si
ce monsieur a réellement ces ambitions
là il faut lui donner un coup de main si
je vous demande votre parti votre
tendance politique aujourd'hui ça serait
quoi à droite ou gauche alors il ya des
tendances un petit peu des deux essais
et c'est un petit peu la nouveauté parce
que autant je peux je me reconnais sûr
beaucoup d'idées de gauche je me
reconnais aussi sur certaines idées de
droite et ceux qui marquent aujourd'hui
ma génération c'est que il ya de bonnes
idées partout et que si en tout cas nous
avons l'ambition de faire en sorte que
la crise structurelle dans laquelle le
pays est depuis plus de 30 ans si nous
avons envie de la dépasser il nous faut
prendre les idées d'où qu'elles viennent
les bonnes idées elles sont partout il
faut prendre les bonnes duquel il et je
me suis même pas posé la question de
savoir s'il est de droite ou de gauche
il est de gauche mais its il serait de
droite ça ne change rien
les idées sont là et c'est ce qui
importe si je reviens sur ma question du
début le nombre de militants s'étant
sentait nous ennuyer avec ce discours là
il a fait combien d'adhésion autour de
lui emmanuel macron dans des parcelles
pas de discours qui fait adhérer ce qui
est vraiment sur le nombre de militants
ont certainement dû y est on est on plus
en plus de 75000 non nationales au
niveau des imams niveau d'équipement si
on veut si je peux vous donner un
chiffre approximatif
je dirais sur en faisant un petit calcul
à partir de ceux qui sont sur versailles
sachant qu'on a à peu près une douzaine
d'agglomération on tournerait autour de
15-20 minutes
ce qui est quand même assez conséquente
est très conséquent je peux samedi nous
avons réuni les membres qui souhaitait
participer aux réunions qui vont venir
il est dans la phase de structuration du
parti nous attendions j'allais dire x
personnes et nous avons une fois 3
aujourd'hui vous êtes en phase de
consultation vous intervenez sur le
terrain ça se passe comment cette phase
de consultation et ça consiste en quoi
alors la fin de la phase de consultation
en elle-même elle est déjà derrière
c'est à dire que nous sommes allés
pendant tout le courant du mois de juin
et du mois de juillet nous sommes allés
à la rencontre des français on a
rencontré
près de cent mille personnes
recueilli plus de 25 mille
questionnaires complets qui nous a
permis de faire un état des lieux et
c'est à dire que nous sommes en train de
le faire de le terminer normalement
d'ici la fin du mois on devrait pouvoir
communiquer sur justement le résultat de
cette grande marche et il faut bien
comprendre que c'était le coeur de
l'action des monnaies le maquereau avant
de proposer quoi que ce soit au pays
pouvoir faire un diagnostic
réelle et crédible et aujourd'hui je
peux vous dire que arriver à mobiliser
15 mai personnes sur tout le territoire
pour faire une enquête grandeur nature
il ya très peu de parties qui en sont
capables une toute dernière questions
liées à l'actualité au dossier alsthom
qui occupe justement
l'actualité depuis depuis ce matin
beaucoup de critiques envers l'ancien
ministre dorénavant de l'économie
emmanuel macron comment voulez vous le
percevez est ce que c'est un coup dur
est ce que ça va peser dans sa cote de
popularité on lui reproche de ne pas
avoir fait ce qu'il fallait et de
quitter le navire un petit peu
maintenant vous avez les mêmes qui
disent aujourd'hui où est il était lui
même puis dix huit qui disait il ya
quelques semaines mais qu'est ce qui
fait encore au gouvernement il n'y a
jamais de fumée sans feu aujourd'hui
beaucoup se rendent compte que emmanuel
macron
suscita réel espoir dont qui dérange
donc il est l'homme à abattre à gauche
comme à droite ça fera pas mais vraiment
anglaise des françaises et des français
aujourd'hui comprennent que ces petites
manoeuvres là n'ont pour seul but de le
déstabiliser
or jusqu'ici il faut le reconnaître
lizaine merci aziz françois n'diaye vous
êtes donc le référent dans les yvelines
2 mouvement en marche merci et nous
poursuivons avec du sport à présent max
vignes et l'emblématique président de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines a donc décidé de passer la main
en cette rentrée il est présent au club
depuis 2003 il cède sa place à jean
pierre pesé que vous avez déjà rencontré
sur notre antenne la semaine dernière
rencontre à présent avec son président
en pleine emblématique qui s'en va la
rencontre avec michael ennemis dont nous
sommes avec max vignes et ancien
président de l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines alors cette
rentrée c'est la première sans vous au
club qu'est ce que ça vous fait tout
simplement vous avez été remplacé par
jean pierre heuzé fait ça mais récemment
et après à l'issue de l'assemblée
générale à l'année dernière donc
officiellement depuis le 2 janvier donc
cette année puisqu'on a pris sa décision
en réunion de bureau
écoutez ça me fait ça me fait d'un côté
ça me fait plaisir parce que ça fait
quand même deux trois ans que je
souhaitais passer la merde donc ça ne
fait plaisir que quelqu'un se soit
décidée et que quelqu'un de motivé
surtout que ce soit pas non plus un
passage de relais en force on va dire
après écoute et pour l'instant
je vais quand même essayer d'aller
peut-être sur les forums mais peut-être
que pour la première fois je n'irai pas
du tout sur un forum ça dépendra de lui
indisponible et madrid non c'est pas que
je vais faire le vide c'est pas une
volonté totalement acquis
m'appartiennent c'est juste que mes
disponibilités
aimé mes obligations professionnelles et
privées ont beaucoup évolué depuis
quelques mois voire de trois ans et je
ne pouvais plus
rendre disons une copie et des
présidents de clubs comme j'ai pu le
faire pendant de longues années donc il
écrit il était temps pour moi de passer
la main vous étiez peut-être un petit
peu usé aussi par votre rôle de
président vous y étiez depuis 2003 oui
depuis longtemps avec
je suis arrivé à lui en cours en 1993 et
depuis 82 je suis dirigeant alors à
l'espoir sportif de lui en cours pendant
cinq six heures j'ai donc à l'entente
athlétique depuis depuis 2003 a fait
depuis la création mais surtout en tant
que jeune fille 2003 pan-allemand on va
dire pendant 13 ans et pensez vous que
votre bilan est positif il y à plus de
800 adhérents maintenant au club c'est
positif joué c'est positif bien sûr
après s'est passé pas le bilan de la
guigne il faut quand même pas ce serait
très inquiétant d'ailleurs de ramener un
projet intercommunal à une somme non
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne heureusement non mais je suis
où je suis plutôt content de ce qu'on a
pu faire à des gens travaillent l'équipe
ça c'était c'était la première des
choses d'avoir rassemblé même si c'est
pas totalement abouti puisque il ya
encore des choses à faire bien
évidemment mais oui bien de bilan ni
même très très positif parce que ça a
été très riche en alcool
amis sont devenus aussi des amis pour
certains d'autres qui ont qui nous ont
quittés depuis pour la province mais il
me donne très très positifs et puis il
ya encore beaucoup de choses à faire et
je suis certaine que la nouvelle équipe
qui se met en place au fur et à mesure
va trouver des nouvelles idées et puis
d'autres d'autres modes de
fonctionnement bien sûr justement y
venir cette nouvelle équipe jean pierre
heuzé après la présidence il est jeune
les dynamiques c'est bien ça et écoute
les rues tout à fait où il réunit tout à
fait tout s'est en fait je ne me
retrouvais un petit peu quand manger
débuté jean pierre à quelqu'un c'est un
jeune trentenaire à peine trentenaire
du temps jeu voilà donc moi j'ai
commencé dans le bénévolat à peu près
dans les rage puisque j'ai été dans le
rugby g de m'occuper athlétique mais
dans une autre en venant de départements
que les yvelines donc oui c'est un
profil je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
a très envie de bien faire est-ce que
vous avez un message adressé à l'entente
synthétique de saint quentin en yvelines
aux adhérents est-ce que vous avez un
message à leur audace et on d'écouter le
message où il est il est simple
ne pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin et
continuer à développer à mettre en
commun parce que ça c'est manger j'ai
toujours défendu sa bon 51 c'est une
ville composée de plusieurs communes je
pense qu'aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de
choses à faire je pense qu'il ya
quelques années c'était dans l'esprit je
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est dans l'esprit
mais c'est surtout aussi dans
malheureusement dans des contraintes
budgétaires et financières qui vont
devenir de plus en plus serrés donc je
pense qu'il y aura aussi une logique
économique a continué à développer les
projets en commun et pas simplement au
sein du club d'athlétisme à 51 et mais
je pense que ça restait valable pour
beaucoup de choses merci beaucoup max
vignes et je voudrais être une bonne
nouvelle vie voilà vous le souhaite
c'est un enchaînement c'est pas ma
nouvelle vie ce sera encore dans cinq
six heures falloir patienter merci
beaucoup merci à vue
le 7 8 les invités se poursuit et il
était également qui se poursuit vous en
avez peut-être profiter en ce début de
semaine ensoleillée et on fasse un
phénomène exceptionnel ou un cycle
habituel les réponses avec elle le
centre météo france jean-françois à doug
et au micro de corinne favre l'idée
était beaucoup plus chaud beaucoup plus
sec
[Musique]
donc le ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel alors
pourquoi en ce moment c'est parce que
bon on a des conditions anticycloniques
qui
dur un petit peu là 2
pic de chaleur disons qu'aujourd'hui et
demain on ouvrait dépassé les 30 degrés
c'est dû à des remontées d'air chaud du
sud-est quoi ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel
puisque en 1947 mais aussi des fortes
températures en 2003 également mené le
30 degrés
en septembre finalement c'est assez
fréquent d'avoir des températures tu
n'es pas ce 30 degrés au moins de 2 700
victoires au changement climatique a
peut-être nôtre et on s'attend en fin de
cycle
fortes températures on accepte en mai
c'est pas
changement climatique le réchauffement
climatique toute façon ils veulent une
augmentation des degrés sur
bezons le croit donc
annie degrés c'est pas c'est pas bio
grêle qu'on a eu
actuellement 1
des patients qui se trouvaient en train
de se creuser sur le golfe de gascogne
et
[Musique]
la remontée dans
vers paris
donc là pour elle devrait être commencer
touché par des averses orageuses et nos
produits après midi et tous dans la
première jeudi
région parisienne et après mercredi donc
changement de ton radical ont perdu
degré
d'événements mais on retrouve à peu près
des littératures de
le sait dans quoi
profitons donc des beaux jours qui est
reine encore un petit peu en ce mois de
septembre c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités replay sur notre site internet
et rendez vous mardi 18h45 pour une
nouvelle édition
[Musique]